the big problem for every democrat
incapable of properly communicating
is of course that they are just too
brilliant for the room there are a whole
lot of people especially people who live
in rural communities who don't there's
no
kinkos there's no office max near them
world breaking genius it's all world
breaking genius
meanwhile joe biden continues to be in a
running gun battle with his teleprompter
it is not going well even the new york
times has now noticed this
according to the new york times even the
president labeled a speech boring
recently in a mission that highlights a
tendency towards delivering
minutia-filled discourse over scaling
oratorical heights
i love how they they really have to
obscure even their own message voters
chose boring over bombast
they got biden's penchant for
pontificating according to michael
shearer
even president biden thought he had been
ponderous i know it's a boring speech
the 46th president said at the end of 31
minutes and 19 seconds filled with
statistics
academic studies global gross domestic
product comparisons and predictions of
7.4
economic growth the president's remarks
on wednesday delivered to a friendly and
respectful crowd of supporters at
mchenry county college in the chicago
suburb
even included reconciliation which mr
biden quickly admitted was a fancy
washington word as the president travels
the country pitching his plan for
spending trillions of dollars to reshape
the american economy he is facing a
rhetorical reality that has long plagued
many of his predecessors
there's a vast difference between
explaining and inspiring and mr biden
who has recently called the explainer in
chief by his press secretary
often struggles to reach the potential
oratorical heights of the office he
holds
mr biden's ambitions are vast the
substance of his presidency has been
dramatic
at times he sometimes describes his
agenda as a way to prove that the very
concept of democracy itself can deliver
for the people the white house is
perfectly fine with mr biden's ability
to turn down the political heat in
washington after four years of chaotic
governance but like
former president barack obama once
delivered a 17-minute answer to health
care question
and bill clinton was forced to apologize
to a late night comic for a dreadful
convention speech mr biden can sometimes
get lost in the minutia okay
i love how the new york times is framing
this joe biden cannot string together
a sentence off teleprompter when he is
on teleprompter he is in a running
battle with the teleprompter and the new
york times frames this says he's too
much of an expert
he's just too with it guys it's not that
joe biden is
entering the early stages of dementia it
is that joe biden is just so
unbelievably with it he is so
into all of the minute details of his
own policy proposals he can send you a
chapter
and verse he'll bore you to tears with
all of the minutia you've noticed by the
way i love that paragraph
barack obama that man was just a policy
wonk just so wonky
bill clinton's so unbelievably wonky i'm
noticing you're leaving out like a few
presidents that happen between here
they all have ours by their names
because it turns out according to the
media every republican
is an idiot dunderhead who can't speak a
sentence and every democrat is
world-beatingly genius
just brilliant you'll remember they made
the same excuse about al gore
al gore was unbelievably boring a
terrible speaker
no charisma and their excuse for why he
lost to george w bush is of course that
al gore was too smart for the room
they said the same thing about john
kerry in 2004. john kerry has never been
in a room where he was too smart for the
room he has not been in a first grade
classroom
as an adult where he was too smart for
the room
and john kerry is one of the stupidest
people alive and yet according to the
new york times and according to the rest
of the media the big problem for every
democrat incapable of
properly communicating is of course that
they are just too brilliant for the room
well one of the other people who is
obviously too brilliant for the room
is kamala harris right the reason that
kamala harris is having her political
struggles right now
is clearly because kamala harris is just
so smart she's just so she's smarter
than you that's why
and you may be looking at her and
watching her on tv and thinking to
yourself
this lady is not super bright like she
says
lots of dumb crap routinely you might i
know you might be thinking that to
yourself
and then you should but you should know
it's you
it's not her it's you so like for
example
over the weekend when she did an
interview with uh bet
in which she um explained that voter id
is racist
because rural people can't get
photocopies
that's all that's just cause she's smart
it's not because she's dumb or out of
touch or doesn't or or or a time
traveler from 1971
it's because she's actually just so
brilliant it's your fault
it's it's like all the conversations
that that the media critics now have
about hollywood whenever a crowd doesn't
like a particular movie or an aspect of
a particular movie that the media want
them to like
is that the crowd is filled with toxic
fandom whenever people are like
yeah you know wasn't so into that that
that character from last jedi i didn't
really like that and they're like
toxic fandom
people weren't into lady ghostbusters
like toxic it's the same thing about
democrats if you don't like a democrat
it's you
it is not it's principal skinner from
from the simpsons it's not me
it's the children who are the problem
it's not it's not kamala harris it's you
who are the problem
so listen to the world breaking genius
of our vice presidents of the united
states who is based
who was selected largely and almost
solely on the basis of her
intersectional qualifications here she
was demonstrating her full-scale genius
in some people's mind
that means well you're going to have to
um xerox or or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinko's there's no office max near them
people have to understand that when
we're talking about voter id laws
be clear about who you have in mind and
what would be required of them to prove
who they are
um what so
here's the thing photocopiers were
invented in the united states in the
1930s
they were widely available pretty much
everywhere by the 1970s so unless she's
a time traveler from 1971 i don't know
what the hell she is talking
about also when is the last time you
actually used a photocopier you have a
printer at your house
i assume because most people have
printers at their house rural or urban
also you don't even have to print crap
now all you have to do is take a picture
of something and you can email to
somebody to print it out for you
or you could just do a scan directly
from your phone
if you got an iphone all you got to do
is go to your notes section
i mean to guide you through how to
actually scan a pdf on your phone but
you can just do it
okay but apparently com world breaking
genius it's all world breaking genius
you know it is this sort of coverage
that i think leads people to a radical
level of institutional distrust
a radical level of of distrust of media
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content